Steve, Nick, congratulations.
The strength of your work,
coupled with your competitors'
failures to perform, have
secured you both a place
in the third round, where we
will send you home to recreate
an iconic blade from history.
Are you ready to see
what that weapon is?
Yes, I am.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Your final challenge
is deerhorn knives.
Whoa.
NARRATOR: Deerhorn knives
are distinctive double-bladed
weapons, used as an
extension of the body
to counter and disarm opponents.
The knives are unique
to the 19th century
martial art form Bagua Zhang.
Students of this
discipline train
with the weapon in both
hands to master techniques
in slashing and seizing.
Easily concealed in
traditional Chinese garb,
these mighty knives can
be swiftly brandished
to catch an opponent off-guard
and deliver deadly cuts
with four horn-shaped points.
The weapons are notably
employed in the film
"Crouching Tiger,
Hidden Dragon."
I've never heard
of a deerhorn knife.
It's definitely not a
design I'm familiar with.
I was hoping for a
fairly simple sword.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
Today I start
the deerhorn knife.
I want to make this thing
look like deer antlers.
I'm used to making
straight pieces.
This thing has curves
all over the place.
And I have to make
two of these things.
Now I have to figure out how I'm
going to make this out of this.
[music playing]
I want to forge this out
of one piece of steel
because that's the
strongest way you can do it.
I'm going to cut a slit down
the center of this bar, spread
the handle and the
front blade apart,
and hopefully it all
is going to go to plan.
[tools whirring]
That looks a lot more
like a deer antler.
Day two, well, I've
decided to do a butt weld.
I'm cutting the crescents
apart and welding it flat on.
So now the edges will line up.
It looks very nice.
Ready to do the heat treat.
(HIGH-PITCHED VOICE) No, no.
I don't want to go
in the fire again.
No!
My only concern right now
is if this weird shape
decides to warp at all,
it could be a problem.
In to quench.
[music playing]
There we go.
That is as hard as a file.
They didn't warp into a pretzel.
So, hey, I'm great.
Day four, I've got both
of these weapons shaped.
It's time to harden them.
This is the moment.
This has to work.
If it doesn't, I'm not
going to have a weapon.
[sizzling]
Hey, no warp-age.
Let's see if we got hardened.
[clanging]
It worked.
I feel really great.
I'm grinding the bevels.
Everything is coming together.
And then I see it.
Uh oh.
I've got a crack in
one of my blades.
That's heartbreaking.
It's going through both ends.
And there's nothing
I can do about it.
I've got to test it.
[thudding]
I need a pole of some kind.
I know they're going to
do something like this.
[music playing]
[thudding]
[clatter]
[sighs]
Day five, I feel like crap.
If it wasn't for the
fact that I'm sick,
I actually kind of like
this deep, gravelly voice.
If I didn't have to hack
up my lung to do it,
I'd have it all the time.
All I have left to
do is put the handles
on and sharpen the blades.
Putting the handles on
is shaping the material
a little bit, gluing
them on, drilling
holes, and putting
the pins in place
to hold everything together.
That's all ready to go.
It's day five, and
I have to start over.
I've got one day to
build a pair of these.
I don't know if I'm going
to be able to do it or not.
If I wasn't the underdog
before, I definitely am now.
I just want to have
something to take there.
I have three days of
work to do in 10 hours.
At this point, I don't
have time for any mistakes.
I just need to stay in the game.
Bladesmiths, to see how
lethal your weapon is,
I will deliver multiple slashes
of thrust on this pig carcass.
Steve, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Absolutely.
Let's
Do this.
I'm really hoping to hear,
you know, it will kill.
[music playing]
Oh.
Well, Steve, you
know, I was surprised,
being that you only have a
scale on one side for the handle
and not on the other.
It is a rustic look.
But, nonetheless, it is actually
comfortable to hold on to.
Your tips over there, sharp
enough to cut, easy to thrust
with the bottom, and deliver
a slice at the same time.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Yeah!
All right, Nick.
You're next.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
[music playing]
Well, Nick, your
weapon is very sharp.
Grabbing your handle, it
feels smooth with both scales
in there.
The angles you have
really lacerate deeply.
And, overall, your
weapon will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Next up is the sharpness test.
To see how sharp your weapons
are, I will take your weapons
and deliver multiple slashes
and stabs on this ballistic bag.
The bag is outfitted with two
poles, which simulates blocks
or blows from pole
weapons these knives
would encounter in battle.
Steve, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
[thudding]
Well, Steve, the
points are sharp.
They lacerate cleanly.
It feels good in the hand.
I can maneuver.
This, sir, will cut.
Thank you.
Nick, you're up next.
You ready?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pretty confident mine can
do at least that well, probably
better, because my
points are more pointier.
[music playing]
[thudding]
Well, Nick, you can see
that it penetrates deep,
the angles you have them
in, and lacerates out.
They're comfortable in the hand.
And your blades will cut.
Thank you.
Next up is strength test.
Dave?
To test the strength
of your weapons,
we're going to clamp them into
our contraption back here.
Once triggered, a staff will
strike the center section
of each of the blades one time
with a force of 2,000 pounds,
simulating the kind of
attacks these weapons could
historically
encounter in combat.
Steve, are you ready?
Yes, I am.
Three, two, one.
[whoosh, clang]
In three, two, one.
Yeah, well, Steve, I
don't see any damage,
any rolling of the edge.
So they held up beautifully.
That's great.
DAVE: Nick?
Just waiting for it.
Waiting for it.
And one, two, three.
[whoosh, clang]
And it broke the stick.
[laughs]
DAVE: Three, two, one.
[whoosh, clang]
Woo!
[laughs] And it broke
the stick again.
All right.
Well, first off, let's
remember that the test
wasn't about breaking sticks.
It was more about
how your blade reacts
to being hit by that stick.
There is no damage whatsoever.
This is still a razor blade.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Well, you've both
done commendable work.
But there can only be
one "Forged in Fire"
champion in this competition.
[music playing]
Nick, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Steve, your weapons
did not make the cut.
Dave will explain.
As Doug said, I really commend
you for doing what you did
on such a compressed timeline.
Thank you.
In the end, it
came down to the fact
that the scales aren't quite on.
There's gapping.
There's still some marks from
where you cut the steel open.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
I understand.
Steve, it's that time.
Please surrender your weapons.
Congratulations.
I'm not surprised
at the result. There
is a natural energy that guides
all of us throughout our lives.
And this is how everything
naturally unfolded.
Unfortunately, it didn't
go my way this time.
But I'll be back.
Nick, congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
How do you feel?
Pretty darn good.
[laughter]
Awesome.
Good job, brother.
That's me.
That's me, the Nick.
I won.
I'm going to hug my
wife when I get home,
and then I'm going
to hug my kitty-cat.
If any of you other
bladesmiths out there are
thinking about it, I say do it.
Try not to have a cold
when you do it though.
[coughs]
[music playing]